Terrorists staged multiple simultaneous attacks in Paris Friday night,...
...killing scores of people with automatic gunfire and explosions.
President Francois Hollande said he was declaring a state of emergency...
..and ordering France's borders closed, an unprecedented act in 21st century Europe.
From Washington, President Barack Obama said the United States was ready to help...
...in any way possible.
A large number of people were being held at a concert hall,...
...where a performance by an American band was interrupted by rapid-fire bursts...
...from Kalashnikov automatic rifles.
Up to a thousand people were in the audience.
Many escaped, but it is not yet clear how many were taken hostage or executed.